You’re the Witcher.
I love the way you just
sit in the corner
and brood.
You smell of death
and destiny.
Heroics and...
heartbreak.
It’s onion.
Right, yeah.
I’m here to drink alone.
Right, so stick close to me,
look mean and
pretend you're a mute.
Can't have anyone finding out
who you actually are.
Geralt of Rivia!
The mighty Witcher!
Oh shit.
Come here.
Yeah?
I’m not your friend.
Oh, are we not using 'friend'?
Yeah sure, let's just give it
another decade.
You have the most
incredible neck.
It's like a...
a sexy goose.
♪When a humble bard♪
♪graced a ride along♪
♪with Geralt of Rivia♪
♪along came...♪
Look, I promised to change
the public’s tune about you.
At least allow me to try.
Let go.
Nope. No.
You horse’s
arse.
I just want some
damn peace!
Well here’s
your peace!
I said some things to him.
He’s a...
A friend?
Look, why don’t we leave
tomorrow?
That is if you’ll give
me another chance.
Why is it whenever I find myself
in a pile of shit
these days
it's you
shovelling it?
That's not fair.
The child surprise.
The djinn.
All of it.
If life could give me
one blessing,
it would be to take you
off my hands.
See you around Geralt.
Fuck it.